- I lost 32 followers on Facebook.
(upbeat techno music)
This might be my biggest
challenge I've ever had.
- I'm super super nervous.
- I'd just like to tell everybody
that I love them and I
hope I get through this.
Would Donald Trump really be that bad?
- I'm not usually one for
bets, but if I was going
to put money down, I'd bet on Trump.
- The one candidate
that seems least likely
to pander to outside groups is Trump.
- That was pretty good.
(dramatic orchestra music)
(click)
(laughter)
- Post.
- It's loading.
- Oh.
- Oh it's up!
- I hate this.
(laughter)
- No way this comment, "Is
this a hostage situation?".
- I lost four followers.
- [Voiceover] No you didn't.
- Yea I did, I swear to God.
- Yours is so long.
- Oh wait, I got one I got one.
- Awww.
- Awwww, no!
- It's been 15 minutes.
(laughter)
- So I've lost eight Facebook followers.
- So far I've lost six Facebook followers.
- You're not going to believe it,
but I'm actually gaining followers.
- So far I've lost 14 followers.
I got 13 likes on status though.
- I just got a frantic
text message from one
of my friends demanding answers.
- I just got a text from my girlfriend
because our friend texted her asking
if I was serious or not.
I'm starting to legitimately feel bad.
- Each time I get a Facebook
notification I just cringe.
- This was a bad idea.
(instrumental rock beat)
- By the end of the day
I was down 31 followers.
- I lost 32 followers.
- There are people in
this world that think
I will vote for Donald Trump.
- A surprising number of
my friends like the status.
- A few people called me out for trolling
and then I started to get like,
people I haven't spoken to since college.
Most of them were angry at me.
- A lot of people yelled at me.
Other people yelled at other people.
It was a typical Facebook argument.
- I would like to apologize
to my Facebook followers.
- That's true.
- I'm sorry I deceived you.
- I'm sorry that I did something
that wasn't really funny.
(upbeat techno music)